Fire Emblem is back and this year it's
leaving the classrooms of three houses
behind here is everything you need to
know about Fire Emblem engage
[Music]
in Fire Emblem engage 1 000 years have
passed since the four kingdoms
cooperated with each other and with
heroes from other worlds to seal away
the fell dragon on the continent of
Elios as the evil prepares to reawaken
you emerge as a leader the Divine Dragon
a chosen hero who can bring back the
heroes from other Realms and seal the
chaos Dragon once again like other Fire
Emblem protagonists alir can be female
or male with a similar red and blue
hairstyle in both instances
[Music]
like other Fire Emblem games engage will
be a turn-based tactical combat game
with a wide array of original characters
that you can upgrade and customize to
your liking your time is split between
the Tactical tile based combat and a hub
area where you can interact with other
characters this non-combat section is a
floating Fortress called the somniel but
hope that thought we'll come right back
to the somnia soon first let's dive into
combat fans of traditional Fire Emblem
games Rejoice engage is bringing back
the weapon triangle a rock paper scissor
mechanic of weapon advantages that was
altered in Fire Emblem 3 houses swords B
axes axes beat Spears and Spears beat
sword taking advantage of the weapons
triangle inflix break which prevents the
defending unit from countering in that
Skirmish weapons outside of the triangle
such as bows daggers and spell tomes are
weak to physical attacks Fire Emblem age
also does away with weapon durability
once you find or purchase a weapon it's
yours to keep this change could mean
less time managing a unit's inventory
and more time battling enemies and
chatting up comrades Fire Emblem is
class based so different classes will
specialize in certain weapon types and
as you upgrade your classes you'll gain
new specializations at the center of
engages combat is the engage mechanic as
you progress through the story you
unlock emblem rings that can be equipped
on any party member each emblem ring
houses the spirit of a character from a
previous Fire Emblem game and when given
to a party member they combine for
improved stats and some powerful
abilities you can mix emblem rings with
any character in your party for varying
effects and strategies some combinations
can lead to incredibly mobile party
members While others could significantly
buff a character's strength stat some
combinations may work better than others
but every party member can force bonds
with every classic character housed in
an emblem ring every Mainline Fire
Emblem game is represented via the
emblem Rings like bonds formed between
units bonds between party members and
emblem Rings increase the effectiveness
of that pair each ring has an upgrade
path for each character in your crew
these upgrade paths can give a character
permanent stat boosts and new skills
that are unique to a specific emblem
ring there are also a handful of tweaks
to moment-to-moment combat as well most
notably now you have direct control over
a character's movement rather than
selecting a unit and plotting a path for
them you can freely move around the
battle before committing to a tile and
attacking it's not a huge change but it
does give a little more flexibility and
precision to your movements and now
let's talk about the non-combat portions
of the game inside the somnil you'll
have access to areas like the plaza
which contains the Armory and the item
shop the ring chamber is home to all of
the emblem Rings you've collected this
is where you can inherit skills from
emblems create and meld Bond rings for
stat boosts and polish your battle
tarnished rings for an even deeper Bond
the arena is the perfect place to
practice your combat skills while still
earning experience and some other
benefits in a familiar vein the Tower of
Trials is a location on the far end of
the somnil that lets you take on a
series of battles in order to earn
in-game rewards but this Hub area isn't
all about buying weapons and practicing
battle scenarios the somnil is also
where you'll get to know your allies
better in Fire Emblem you're not just
chatting with buddies for the hell of it
the game also tends to give bonuses for
units battling side by side if they've
developed special Bonds in the
non-combat portions since food is
perfect at bringing people together you
can share a meal with a friend at the
cafe Terrace not hungry give your allies
a gift instead to deepen your bond other
activities in the somnia include fishing
fortune telling wyvern riding managing a
farm yard buying clothes at the boutique
and partaking in some strength training
for temporary stat Buffs
[Music]
Fire Emblem engage is set to release on
January 20th 2023 exclusively for the
Nintendo switch pre-orders are available
right now and there are two editions of
the game standard and divine the
standard edition digital and physical
comes with the base game and nothing
more the Divine Edition comes with the
base game as well as a steelbook case
our cards an art book and a pretty cool
poster but beware the Divine Edition
sold out quickly so it may be harder to
find there will be four paid DLCs that
will launch throughout 2023 with the
first wave of the expansion becoming
available the same day as the base game
on January 20th this first wave includes
additional support items new accessories
a silver card and additional emblems
like the emblem bracelet for edogard
Dimitri and Claude all in one and
another for Tiki Fire Emblem engage
brings back a lot of familiar faces and
a core mechanic is being able to summon
Fire Emblem Heroes to the battlefield
players can probably expect the other
waves of DLC to also include pass Fire
Emblem characters from different titles
that's everything you need to know about
Fire Emblem and Gage the classrooms are
gone and the weapons triangle is back
there are more than enough old faces to
tug at your Nostalgia for the series and
plenty of activities to get lost in
outside of battle drop a comment below
letting us know your favorite Fire
Emblem game thus far for more videos on
engage including our review keep it
locked to GameSpot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]